لقد عدنا بمزيد من الأخبار العاجلة عن
غارة حماس الضخمة والمميتة على إسرائيل
لمعرفة المزيد عما يحدث، انضممت إلينا
الآن من قبل آرا هالفي، رئيس سابق
لجهاز المخابرات الإسرائيلي، شكرًا
جزيلاً لانضمامك إلينا، كنت رئيس الموساد
للمخابرات الإسرائيلية  الخدمة لقد
رأيت إسرائيل تتعرض للهجوم عدة
مرات من قبل هل سبق لك أن رأيت
هجومًا مثل هذا تمامًا
لا أعتقد أن هذا هجوم فريد من نوعه
أه لقد واجهنا أه إخفاقات استخباراتية
من قبل وتفاجأنا ولكن هذه هي
المرة الأولى  أن أه أهل
غزة تمكنوا من اختراق
إسرائيل في عمق إسرائيل وأه
السيطرة على قرى أه في الجنوب
ليس فقط على الحدود مع قطاع غزة ولكن
إلى حد ما أيضا أعمق في إسرائيل أه
وفي مدن أه تماما ولا  شمال ولا
شمال من في أه أماكن أه على طول
شاطئ البحر ح كما تعلم شنت حماس
هذا الهجوم الكبير المتطور إلى حد ما في
الذكرى الخمسين
لحرب يوم 1973 هل تعتقد أن
الجيش الإسرائيلي وأجهزة المخابرات
أخطأت بعض العلامات الحمراء المهمة في عدم
الفهم  ما كان
يحدث نعم أه بالفعل ولكن قصة عام 1973
كانت مختلفة
لأنه كانت لدينا فترة ما قبل
الحرب وكان لدينا تقييمات خاطئة لما
كان سيفعله الطرف الآخر
إذا لم يكن لدينا في هذه الحالة أي شيء
إنذار مبكر من أي نوع وكانت
مفاجأة تامة أن الحرب اندلعت
هذا
الصباح ما هو وضع
العمليات الاستخبارية الإسرائيلية وقدرتها
على مراقبة أنشطة حماس في غزة
الآن السيد ح
حسنًا لديهم قدرات من الواضح
أه لكن في هذا الخصوص  إذا أه هذه
القدرات خذلتهم أعتقد
على الرغم من أه على الأرجح أه في
الساعات القليلة الماضية أه بذلت جهود معينة
أه تحسين أه القدرة على تغطية
ما يحدث هناك وكذلك
الاستعداد للهجوم المضاد الذي
من المحتمل أن يبدأ أو قد بدأ في
الساعات القليلة الماضية تعطينا تحليلك، إن
شئت، لمستوى التنسيق
والتعقيد لهجوم حماس هذا
من غزة إلى إسرائيل بالصواريخ، غزو بري، غزو
باستخدام الزوارق الشراعية
السريعة للهجوم من قبل SE مما أسفر عن
مقتل واختطاف الكثير من
المدنيين الإسرائيليين وأخذهم  في غزة أعطونا
إحساسكم جيدًا بأنها عملية كانت
ناجحة جدًا لسوء الحظ أعتقد أنها كانت
منسقة بشكل جيد وأعتقد أنهم كانوا قادرين
على إبقاء الأمر سرًا ولم يكن لدينا أي فكرة
أن هذا يجري تم
التخطيط له أه أه وحتى أه في بعض الحالات
ربما كانوا قادرين على أه أه محاولة إجراء
تجربة أه تدريب ولم يكن
لدينا أي فكرة أه عما يحدث
على الرغم من أن تغطية أه
قطاع غزة
بالإمكانات الاستخباراتية لدينا كانت جداً جداً أه
عالية جداً  اه أود أن أقول اه اه
ناجح جدا في السنوات الماضية وأعتقد أنه
أحد الإخفاقات الاستخباراتية الكبرى
للإسرائيليين وصححوني إذا كنت مخطئا يا
سيد هالفي أه هو أن حماس تمكنت من
دخول غزة بآلاف الصواريخ
والقذائف التي أطلقوها  الآن يطلقون
على أهداف مختلفة في إسرائيل إسرائيل
تحاصر قطاع غزة كيف تمكنوا من
ذلك بشكل جيد أه أطلقوا هذه الصواريخ
بكميات لم نرها من قبل
عدد الصواريخ التي
أطلقوها في أقل من 24 ساعة
أكثر من 3000 صاروخ  هذا أه فوق
الخيال من وجهة نظرنا
ولم نكن نعرف وكان لديهم هذه
الكمية من أه الصواريخ وبالتأكيد
لم نتوقع أنها ستكون
فعالة كما هي اليوم ولكن كيف
أدخلوها إلى غزة كلها  هذه
الصواريخ أعتقد أن الكثير منها
صنعت بنفسها أه لديها
قدرة تصنيعية في
قطاع غزة أه ربما حصلوا على عدد قليل منها
من إيران أه ومع ذلك تم تهريبها
عن طريق البحر ولكن في الأساس
هو أه الإنتاج المنتج
الذي  لديهم داخل قطاع غزة